well Jewish and Muslim groups in the US
say hate crimes are on the rise as the
Gaza Israel war drags on in Chicago a
six-year-old boy was fatally stabbed
while his mother was severely injured
police say they were targeted because of
their faith the suspect Joseph Juba was
the family's landlord he has been
charged with hate crimes Palestinian
American wad Al fume had just turned six
years old his mother is in critical
condition Ahmed rhab is the executive
director of the Council on American
Islamic relations in Chicago he says
some Us Media Outlets have dehumanized
Palestinians and believes this is
contributing to the rise in hate crimes
the media in the United States has been
so lopsided and one-sided on this issue
Fanning the Flames of essentially
dehumanization and demonization of
Palestinians and so you have this man
who committed this crime he had never
had any issues with his neighbors these
tenants of his up until he started
watching the recent cycle of news and he
was radicalized we always always ask who
radicalizes in this case I'm pointing
the blame in part at least to our
officials and our media and the
irresponsible coverage of what's
happening in Palestine that dehumanizes
Palestinians in social media there's
more of a chance for uh two sides to the
story two opinions about what is
happening uh to emerge we're not seeing
that in the broadcast or print media
certainly not in the statements of
officials however even in social media
unfortunately we are seeing a censoring
an active censor
of positions that support Palestinian
essentially human rights this isn't even
I mean I'm not aware of anybody in my
circle or in my community who's
supporting you know terrorist acts
against Israelis or attacks against
Israelis of any kind civilians however
what we are seeing is even standing up
for the human rights of Palestinians and
speaking out against the aggression the
occupation the um the oppression that's
happened for decades that's led us into
this conflict the root of this conflict
but even the what's happening right now
in terms of the mass murder essentially
war crimes that were happening in Gaza
that alone might be sufficient to get
somebody Shadow banned on Facebook or
have their account you know uh
challenged or have a post taken down so
even on social media we're seeing a
challenge to free speech